Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh Nhiêu thuốc và Excel bài
số 3 nhóm các hàm tính tổng trước khi
bắt đầu bài học số 3 hãy thì mình sẽ
cùng giải đáp câu hỏi của bài tập số 2
nhá Đấy thì bạn xem ở cái câu hỏi của
bài tập số hai lên các bạn chú ý nếu như
bạn nào mà không biết cách tải file thực
hành cũng như file Câu hỏi thì các bạn
xem video đầu tiên là cái video mở đầu
của cái loạt Bài học này nhá câu hỏi số
1 Có thể thêm các công cụ khác vào thanh
truy cập nhanh các tầng Mai Quick access
toolbar hay không thì câu trả lời là có
nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ mở cái file Excel
lên mình dẫn các bạn ạ phải gọi vào
start chọn gói Xem Gọi enter nhá Mình sẽ
chọn bọn anh gốc đi đấy thì cái Quick
access toolbar Ở đây bây giờ các bạn sẽ
tích và cái tam giác sau xuống đây này
thích hình biểu tượng Nhỏ đây này chọn
tích vào đây các bạn sẽ chọn thì các bạn
sẽ chọn cái mo farah bây giờ trong cái
phần Fortuner Hormon này các bạn có thể
chọn Ôn
I come as lại thì như vậy toàn bộ toàn
bộ các chức năng ở bên lành nó sẽ có đây
thì lớn như các bạn cần cái chức năng
nào mà có bạn hay dùng đấy thì họ sẽ đẩy
sang cái cuốc setool3 bây giờ ví dụ mình
làm xuống nhá Nếu như mình chọn cái mất
đúng không còn sự tích đấy các bạn gọi
chị m này nó sẽ nhảy xuống cái tên mà
bắt đầu bằng chữ m đây machine Center
mình hay dùng là chẳng hạn thế nào biết
tôi thật sự thích ở đây các bạn sẽ bấm
tích và cái mất Exciter này mà mình hay
dùng hạt đấy nha cọ sẽ 4S thì các bạn
thấy cho cái bước Exciter nó sẽ sang đây
rồi nhá đấy hoặc các bạn tìm thêm một
cái nữa đi cái nào mà có ăn hay dùng thì
bạn ấy nhá nên về namie filename đây ví
dụ khi Format là number format Nhắc gọi
E và đã đây mình làm mẫu Thôi vậy Các
bạn bấm ok còn thấy cho nó thêm cái gì
đây Cái phần trăm này và cái mất Center
bây giờ giả sử Mình đang ở cái thẻ data
đi rồi bây giờ mình có bốn hiểu mình hộp
4 Cái ô này ạ Bên mình muốn mua xe
Exciter đúng không ạ
có thể hôm ấy thì bạn tích khuôn vào cái
ta này lại mốc Exciter gọn thấy cho nó
sẽ đổ và luôn và ko thích nước vào đây
Đấy nó sẽ nằm ở giữa đây là quan nhập dữ
liệu ấy Còn nếu không rất là hay các bạn
có thể mất cứ ở cái thẻ nào Thế bạn chỉ
diện tích với đây thôi là sẽ nó mốt lại
Đấy bây giờ để xóa đi thì mình làm thế
nào cũng các bạn cũng làm ngược lại thôi
các bạn tích vào đây Các bạn chọn mo
farah đợi ví dụ cái này mình không cần
dùng nhiều nữa nhé các bạn sẽ thích bộ
đây các bạn sẽ remove Tức là mình thấy
bảy về bên này mất Center cũng thế Mình
Limo để mình sẽ ok thì như vậy hai cái
công vụ kia nó sẽ không nằm ở trên cái
cuốc setool3 này nữa nhá câu hỏi xuống
hay là có thể thay thế Phone và cỡ chữ
mặc định khi tạo một file mới hay không
thì cái này là có nhá bằng cách nhận đây
mình sẽ vào thì hôm rồi Đây là cái file
mới vừa xong tạo ra đúng không Các bạn
thấy cái mặc định carazy cỡ chữ là 11
đúng không Bây giờ mình muốn thay đổi
khi mình phải tạo một file mới thì cái
cỡ chữ và cái Phong sẽ thay đổi đúng
không Thì gọi cho vào cái file này
cho các bạn xem vào more mình sẽ vào
option đấy các bạn sẽ vào với Giroud ấy
nhé các bạn thấy chưa nó sẽ có cái mũ
của đây là quan creating new work book
tức là khi các bạn tạo một Facebook lại
thịt cái miệng cái đi photo chứng là cái
Phong mặc định là ba Bphone 2 Ví dụ mình
đổ này nhá các bạn có thể đổi bất kỳ cái
phone nào Ví dụ lại Arirang à thế này
cưới chứ là 13 giản thế nhé khoảng 14 đi
lấy những học sinh 14 thì bạn có thể gọi
trực tiếp vào đây là 13 học được ví dụ
mình để lên 13 để gọi m đấy thì nó sẽ
hiện của cái thông báo là mình phải đóng
cái file lại và mình khởi động lại Excel
thì nó mới có tác dụng nha các bạn muốn
Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ sóng wifi đến các đội
xếp đi bây giờ mình sẽ mở Excel lên nhá
Nó sẽ có phải là Phong Arirang và cỡ chữ
10 mai không thích xe này enter các bạn
Blanc mốc này đấy gọi thế chứ Đây là cái
không Arirang và cỡ chữ được 13 rất là
hai ạ Bây giờ mình bắt lại nha các bạn
vào file more options lại còn
anh cái thẻ Zalo đây đây mình không phải
Arirang nữa mình quay về cái lại bắt đầu
đi làm borofone đây là cái cái cái chữ
đồng 11 thôi nhé Hãy gọi thêm Ok Ok mình
sẽ đóng cái file này okay tiếp theo mình
sẽ vào với bài 3 nhá các bạn chú ý các
bạn cần tại cái folder của bài 3 này về
nhắc sau đó bạn mở cái folder này lên
lại mình sẽ vào cái file thực hành của
cái bài số 3 của bạn tích lũy vào đây
nhóm các hàm tính tổng Gọi Thúy hôm nay
mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn ba cái hàm
tính tổng làm song song ít và sau mép
nhé thì đầu tiên nên là mình đã hướng
dẫn các bạn thấy cú pháp rồi thì làm
xong thì cú pháp là lìa xăm bạn 5m 15 m2
đấy 5 bộ là các số nhá và các cô và các
vùng sạm ít là tính tổng có điều kiện và
sulfat là tính tổng có nhiều điều kiện
rất là ví dụ mình tính tổng có hai hoặc
ba điều kiện thì mình không thể dùng để
làm xong ít được mà mình phải dùng cái
hàng sau phép Ok đầu tiên mình sẽ giới
ở đây về hình xăm ở đây là xong chứ
không phải sao biết sao mà mình sẽ giới
thiệu qua về cách để mình nhập hàm nhá
để nhập hàng trong Excel ấy thì các bạn
có thể bấm dấu cộng rồi các bạn gõ là
cái hàm tương ứng và ví dụ xăm đây lại
hoặc gì ạ Các bạn sẽ có tấm bằng thì
thông thường người ta hay gọi dâu bằng
chứ không có dấu cộng các bạn sẽ bằng
nhá Sau đó bạn sẽ nhập với tên hàng thì
ở đây mình đăng nhập cái hình xăm còn gõ
chữ s này thịt khi các bạn gõ chữ s xong
thì ít xe nó sẽ tự động nó gợi nhắc này
tất cả các hàng mà sẽ bắt đầu bằng chữ s
đấy gọn năng số này tất cả các hàng mà
bắt đầu bằng chữ s ví dụ Các bạn có thêm
chữ nữa đấy thì nó sẽ tất cả các hàng mà
bắt đầu bằng chữ Fu thì có hàm xuất
huyết tiêu này sắp tôi thờ thả thế Đây
là hình xong thì có 2 cách nhập hàng
xong các bạn gõ thêm chị m hoặc các bạn
tích đúng và làm xong nào đấy ví dụ mình
xóa đi nhé đấy hoặc các bạn gõ cho chữ m
nữa thì tùy các bạn nhá ở đây ví dụ minh
tích lũy và làm xong rồi đi thì thành
phần của làm xong rồi điện 5m 153
Khi xăm mình muốn tính tổng của ba này
phẩy 7,6 phẩy 8 phẩy 9 hệ 4 vé số này
nha các bạn enter đấy thì nó sẽ ra là 33
đúng không còn tức lúc để sửa công thức
nhé hoặc phím tắt là các bạn xem bấm F2
để các bạn sửa cái công thức là ví dụ
còn phải là ngoài 40 số này thì bạn muốn
Bôi đen một số vùng ở đây nữa Tức là đêm
47 này phải nữa hoặc là cái vùng thêm
cái vùng này nữa Từ D15 đến đêm 17 nữa
lại các bạn enter đấy Bạn thấy chứ lúc
này nó ra là chín triệu đấy là cái cách
sử dụng hàm xong thì trong bài tập hôm
nay mình sẽ tính tổng doanh thu nhá thì
còn chửi nhà ở đây mình có ba cái thông
tin là khu vực này sản phẩm là và doanh
thu đấy thì mỗi khu vực nó sẽ có ở đây
tất cả là 5 sản phẩm đúng không ạ và khu
vực ở đây mình sẽ có 3 khu vực Bắc Trung
Nam bây giờ mình sẽ tự tính tổng doanh
thu với vùng này nhá Đấy bây giờ các bạn
sẽ thích vào cái OVA 4 để các bạn Nhập
công thức tính tổng nhá các bạn sẽ bằng
này em là xong đúng không Các bạn có thể
ấn top này hoặc các bạn mở ngoặc
Ừ thì bây giờ để lựa chọn toàn bộ cái
vùng doanh thu thì có 2 cách nhá thì đầu
tiên các bạn sẽ tích vào ô đầu tiên của
cái vùng Doanh thu là cái ô gì od4 sau
đó bạn giữ thật trái và các bạn kéo
xuống đấy mình rất kéo từ cái od4 đến
bd18 này sau đó còn bỏ tiền trái ra để
gọi enter thì nó sẽ ra tổng doanh thu là
16 triệu tám trăm đúng không Bây giờ các
bạn thích đúng để các bạn sửa này hoặc
các bạn Nhập lại nha khoa có thể bằng
xong để gọi nhập lại là thì Cách thứ hai
là gì có sự tích bằng ô đầu tiên của cái
vùng dữ liệu này sau đó bạn giữ cần
thương ship và ấn mũi tên xuống đây thì
nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu
ở đây các bạn em Thơ đấy chỉ 2 cách để
mình lựa chọn cái vùng dữ liệu nhá thì
thông thường nếu như cái vùng dữ liệu mà
một ít thì các bạn sẽ dùng cách một là
còn giữ được trái và các bạn Bôi đen còn
nếu như cái vùng dữ liệu của bạn dài Ví
dụ nó hàng trăm nghìn thì bạn phải giữ
tiền lương trí của mũi Yên xuống nó sẽ
nhanh hơn là bạn sẽ Di chuột nhé Đây là
hai cái cách là mình Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ
liệu tính tổng đúng không tiếp theo là
hỗ trợ các bạn cái hàm sao biết thì cái
hành xe buýt nó khác gì mới làm xong
xong ít thì nó sẽ kết hợp của cái hàng
xong và cái Hà mít cái ý bị trong tiếng
Anh nó là cái Nếu tức là có điều kiện
thì ở đây bản chất là tính tổng có điều
kiện đúng không Thì cái điều kiện ở
trong cái ví dụ Thứ hai này là tính tổng
theo khu vực thì trong cái ví dụ đầu
tiên mình tính tổng là mình tính tổng
toàn bộ ba khu vực và toàn bộ các sản
phẩm đây nhưng mà trong cái ví dụ Thứ
hai này mình tính tổng theo khu vực tức
là doanh thu của Việt Bắc là một số
doanh thu của Việt Nam là một số và
doanh thu về miền Trung là một số đúng
không thì các bạn phải tính tổng có điều
kiện thì mình có thể dùng làm sạch tiếp
nhé các bạn bằng xe buýt các bạn có thể
tắt này đấy thì đầu tiên là cái duyên
Tức là cái vùng điều kiện nhá Thì cái
vùng điều kiện của mình đang làm gì Mình
đang tính tổng theo khu vực đúng không
Thì cái vùng điều kiện phải là cái vùng
khu vực ở đây thì có bôi đen toàn bộ váy
phần khu vực Ở đây chỉ có 2 cách để
Model Lúc nãy mình nói rồi đúng không
Đấy còn có thể giữa
ơ hoặc các bạn thích bởi đầu tiên bạn
giữ gần chân suýt nữa lên xuống đây là
hai cách để mình đen vùng dữ liệu đúng
không phải tiếp theo là cái điều kiện
đúng không cái điều kiện chính là cái ô
ô F9 ở đây này để họ phân tích bằng iOS
9 chính là cái điều kiện đấy phải cái
thành phần thứ ba này Các bạn nhìn thấy
nó tô đậm lên ở đây là xong lên Tức là
khi và đã thỏa mãn với điều kiện là khu
vực phía Bắc rồi thì mình sẽ tính tâm
cái gì mình sẽ tính tổng theo doanh thu
đó Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng Doanh thu là
c4d 18 đấy các bạn xem đó ngược lại Để
sau này các bạn em tơ đấy thì như vậy
tổng doanh thu của khu vực phía Bắc là
từng này các bạn sẽ tích và cái order
chí này các bạn vào thẻ hô để mình rất
thích vào cái dấu phẩy đây này để mình
ngăn cách các khách hàng nghìn với nhau
nhìn nó sẽ dễ hơn đúng không Mình nhìn
một phát thì biết ngay là gì hơn 6 triệu
đấy bây giờ để áp dụng công thức của cái
tính tổng của khu vực phía Bắc cho miền
Trung và miền Nam thì mình là như thế
nào thì các bạn giữ được trái và cái góc
dưới ở bên phải thế này khi nào mà nó
hiện
Ừ thì có thức lúc nhé để cậu tính lui
vào đây đấy Bạn thấy thì như vậy Excel
nó rất là thông minh đã sẽ tính tổng lực
là miền Trung và miền Nam lại nhưng mà
đây chưa Đúng không các bạn chú ý nhé
Bây giờ chọn sẽ tích mà cái miền Trung
đây này thì bạn thấy cho cái vùng dữ
liệu của mình nó lại bị dịch một ô đấy
Lúc nãy mình tính tổng một bát thì nó là
từ cái hàng thứ Tư này Bây giờ mình tính
thẩm miền Trung nó lại từ hàng thứ 5 từ
B5 Và đây là từ đêm năm có bạn thấy đấy
Bạn thấy cái vùng mà nó tô màu lên đây
này thì như vậy nó chưa thực sự chính
xác đúng không lại để sửa cái này mình
làm như thế nào các bạn đồng ý tiếp nhé
mình sẽ thích vào cái mũi tên này ăn đu
lại Bây giờ mình xuất xưởng với công
thức này các bạn thích đúng vậy đó Bây
giờ con sẽ Bôi đen Cái B1 jb18 đây này
Đấy ta sẽ nhấn F4 nhá
bí ẩn F4 là diện Tức là mình sẽ thêm cái
đôla chiếc hàng và chiếc cổ đây còn thấy
chưa đô la trước b là đô la trước số 4
đôla trước B và Đôla trước 18 tiếp tục
các bạn Model d4dd 18 là các bạn sẽ nhấn
F4 thì các bạn Thúy Nga một số bạn mà ấn
F4 không được thì các bạn có thể giữ
thêm những nút tăng sừng và ở nét 4 nhá
Đấy là tùy cái máy tính chế độ Bố bạn
Tại vì thông thường những cái phím F4
của bạn nó sẽ có 2 chức năng đúng không
Thì có thể các bạn đang chọn cái mặc
định không phải là chức năng F4 cho nên
các bạn phải giữ phân xưởng F4 Còn nếu
như các bạn chọn chức năng mặc định lẽ
bốn thì gọi không cần giữ nút tăng sức
nữa nhé đấy là cái cách một số bạn hãy
hỏi lại bây giờ cạn em tâm đấy thì kết
quả đây vẫn là giống nhau về bạn thích
nụ cười đây này Đấy còn thấy được kết
quả khác nhau với cả lúc trước bây giờ
mình sẽ kích đúp vào cái công thức của
mình chung cậu ở đây cho cái vùng dữ
liệu của mình Lúc nãy nó sẽ không dịch
nữa đấy Tại vì sao Bởi vì mình cố định
rồi cái đôla đây là cố định tức là khi
các bạn áp dụng với công thức này cho
các cái phần dưới này ạ thì cái vùng dữ
liệu
các bạn có đôla thì nó sẽ không bị dịch
chuyển đấy gọn hiểu yếu ạ thì lúc đấy mà
chưa có lại thì cái này nó sẽ dịch
chuyển giới hành trước năm và cái này sẽ
được chuyển cho rằng số 6 nhưng mà có
đôla bọn đấy chứ nó vẫn ở hành số 4 rồi
Đây là cái cái vùng dữ liệu bạn không
được đấy là cái cách mà các bạn cố định
nhé Ok Đấy là mình hướng dẫn các bạn là
hướng dẫn là để các bạn hiểu là tại sao
lại cố định thôi bây giờ ví dụ mình xóa
đi Thông thường mình sẽ nhập mình sẽ làm
như sau này các bạn sẽ bằng xe buýt lấy
còn đứng tác đây đầu tiên là cái cùng
điều kiện đúng không để gọi sẽ Bôi đen
cái khu vực ở đây và các bạn F4 luôn đấy
thì lúc này các bạn không phải bôi lên
nữa mà khi các bạn chọn vùng xong thì
các bạn ấy mét bốn luôn thì nó sẽ cố
định đúng không phải theo cái điều kiện
ở đây phải cái vùng tính tổng là diện là
cái B4 đến diện B18 mà đấy các bạn cũng
F4 luôn đấy thì lúc này thì nó sẽ cố
định toàn bộ vùng nó bạn chọn Đây này
cái còn đóng mặc lại Rồi enter đây thì
nó sẽ ra là sáu triệu Thế còn đều rất là
hai ạ Đây là cái xe buýt nhé à
trực tiếp theo mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
cách hàng sau ghép thì sao biết nó khác
gì với cả các clip ở đây mình sẽ có hai
cái điều kiện điều kiện thứ nhất là tính
tổng doanh thu theo khu vực phía Bắc này
việt-trung này ở miền Nam nhưng mà diện
cho các sản phẩm 01 Thôi thì như vậy Ở
đây là có hai điều kiện theo cái sản
phẩm và theo khu vực Đúng thế đoạn không
thể dùng làm sao biết được bởi vì sắp ít
là tính tổng có một điều kiện thôi đấy
thì các bạn sẽ ở đây mình sẽ bằng cm này
còn mở ngoặc thì thành phần đầu tiên của
cái hàm cm là cái xong lên thì ăn chuối
nha Cái Sulli pet này nó khác với cả sắp
ít tại vì cái xong ít thì cái xong rên
nó lại là cái cuối cùng cơ trong khi cái
hàng sau ghép thì xong lên đó lại là ở
cái vùng đầu tiên để cho nên cái vùng
đầu tiên của mình phải mua đem toàn bộ
doanh thu này đúng ạ và các bạn hãy nhớ
lại F4 Tại sao lại phải là F4 ạ tại vì
mình sẽ áp dụng công thức này cho các ở
dưới này tức là cho miền Trung và miền
Nam đúng không Thì mình phải bấm F4 để
cái vùng này nó sẽ không bị dịch chuyển
ở vùng tổng doanh thu này nó sẽ không bị
dịch chuyển đấy phải tiếp theo là cái
vùng điều kiện thứ nhất giả sử cái điều
kiện thứ nhất là mình theo khu vực đúng
không thì các bạn xem đem đến khu vực ở
bên trái này các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 này cố
định cái cùng điều kiện này ạ phải để
cái điều kiện là theo khu vực chính là
cái ô F16 làm ạ Đấy phẩm tiếp theo là
cái vùng điều kiện thứ Hai điều kiện thứ
hai là cho sản phẩm Đúng không các bạn
lại Bôi đen Cái cục C nhà ngã tư từ c4d
18 các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 để cố định đấy
phần theo điều kiện sản phẩm ở trên này
là cái ô g14 nhưng mà còn chúng á Cái ô
g14 này các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 để cố định
tại vì sao lại phải cố định cái g14 Tại
vì khi các bạn áp dụng với công thức cho
cá tôm dưới này thì bây giờ mày bố nó sẽ
không bị dịch chuyển nó vẫn là Theo các
điều kiện sản phẩm 01 ở đây thôi đúng
không ạ Đấy bạn enter thì nó sẽ ra là
tổng đây còn thích đút vào đây mình sẽ
chọn cái dấu phẩy là ngắn ngăn cách hàng
nghìn cho dễ hiểu bây giờ quên sẽ kích
đúp vào cái công thức ở miền Nam cuối
cùng để quan kiểm tra gọi lại cho
sự kiện này nó không bị dịch chuyển lại
Tại vì lúc đấy Mình đã cố định Kyo gồm
14 rồi đấy trong khi ở đây cái khu vực
thì nó sẽ dịch chuyển theo đúng không ạ
rất là hai ạ Bây giờ mình Đố các bạn nhé
Mình có thể dùng cái hàng xong mới biết
cho cái hàng xóm ít này không cho cái ví
dụ Thứ hai này không hoàn toàn có thể
nhá đây tại vì làm xong ít là cho nhiều
điều kiện mà một điều kiện để lại thừa
sức Mời gọi sẽ bằng này sao hết đấy thì
thành phần đầu tiên nó khác với cái xe
buýt là gì Cái Thành Phần đầu tiên là
cái vùng tính tổng thì bạn Bôi đen Cái
vùng viện vùng doanh thu đấy thôi các
bạn nhấn F4 này cố định phẩy tiếp theo
là tính điều kiện cho khu vực đúng không
là cái vùng điều kiện thì bạn Bun I cái
vùng khu vực ở đây để chọn sẽ nhấn F4 để
cố định phải theo điều kiện là khu vực ở
đây đấy vì ở đây chỉ có một điều kiện
cho đúng không Con sẽ đóng mọc luôn các
bạn enter đây các bạn Facebook vào đây
phải gọi ông rất là 2 à Thì mình khuyên
các bạn nhé Nếu như mà các bạn dùng cái
hòm xong mà có một điều kiện thì các bạn
cũng nên dùng làm sao Z đ
Vì sao tình hai cái cú pháp này nó khác
nhau cho nên nếu các bạn dùng cả hai thì
nhiều khi các bạn sẽ bị lẫn này Thế gọi
nhầm thì tốt nhất là các bạn dùng cái
hàm cm các bạn có thể dùng trong một
điều kiện còn nhiều điều kiện đều được
vào cái cú pháp Các bạn dùng quen thì nó
sẽ không bị nhầm nhé Đây là cách cạnh mà
mình khuyên các bạn là như vậy Ok như
vậy Mình chất tổng kết lại cái bài học
số 3 ngày hôm nay nhé các bạn chú ý nhá
Cái làm xong các bạn có thể xong một ô
nhiều ô hoặc các bạn nhiều vùng các bạn
thêm số đều được nhé Còn cái hàng xăng
ít và làm sao biết đấy thì cái quan
trọng nhất là gì Thông thường các cái
vùng điều kiện và cái vùng tính tổng là
các bạn phải cố định đấy hầu như là mình
phải cố định chưa bao giờ mình gặp là
không cố định cả Tại vì khi mình áp dụng
công thức cho các cô sau thì cái vùng
điều kiện và cái vùng tính tổng nó sẽ
không bị dịch chuyển Đấy đấy là cái chú
ý thứ nhất cách chú ý Thứ hai là mình
thấy lên dùng hàm xanh mét với cả một
điều kiện thì mình cũng nên dùng làm sao
mép để ạ
em của xóm xs và sắp được khác nhau để
tránh nhầm lẫn thì mình lên dùng một cái
Hà thôi Làm sao biết ghét nhé và các bạn
thứ nhất để cố định thì bạn sẽ dùng cái
phím F4 hoặc là phân xưởng F4 nhưng mà
trong trường hợp mà gì ạ Mà cái phím F4
của bạn hỏng đấy hoặc sáng sớm F4 của
bạn học Thế bạn làm như thế nào Okay Giả
sử cái kính nhỏ nhau mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn này các bạn cứ sao biết đi thấy
thì đầu tiên ở vùng tính cổng đúng không
Bây giờ xử lý kính F4 lòng không làm
được có cắm cứ phải đi tiếp theo là vùng
điều kiện của các bạn Bôi đen những vùng
điều kiện này với bạn phải là Theo các
điều kiện thì bác là đấy các bạn diện
tích chuột vào cái trước đê này các bạn
các bạn gõ kinh đô la Thôi bằng cách các
bạn giữ VSIP và bạn Nhím đôla thôi Tại
Donna SO4 này đợt tức là thay vì nếu như
phím F4 bị hỏng thì còn phải chịu khó
nhập tay không nhận đấy lại cách mà mình
hướng dẫn các bạn này nếu như phím F4
hội vẫn học thì cái này buộc các bạn
phải dùng tay cái này mình không quen
lắm lại sau đó còn enter đi bây
ở lại rất là hay thì trước khi kết thúc
bài học ngày hôm nay thì mình sẽ ra các
bạn bài tập về nhà nhá Đấy còn quả
folder của bài số 3 này đây gọi sẽ tích
và cái câu hỏi đây Đây là cái file câu
hỏi nhá Thì các câu hỏi của mình sẽ
Luyện tập là gì mình tiếp tục luyện tập
cái hàm cfs Thì cái này nó sẽ ngược với
cái ví dụ 3 ở trên là gì mình sẽ tính
tổng theo cái sản phẩm đây và cái khu
vực nó lại nằm ở phía trên này có đây
thì về nhà cũng xuất hiện ở đây nhá Để
vào sau khi các bạn nhỏ công suất người
các bạn sẽ đổi ra Ví dụ khu vực phía Bắc
các bạn đổi thành miền Trung và miền Nam
thì gọi xem cái kết quả nó có thay đổi
không nhá và cái bài số 2 trong cái bài
tập về nhà là diện sai ghép ở đây là ba
điều kiện cho Tức là mình sẽ vẫn tính
tổng theo khu vực và theo các sản phẩm
vào đây nhưng mà mình chỉ tính tổng cho
các sản phẩm và có doanh thu lớn hơn
800.000 Thôi để gọn hiểu ví dụ cái sản
phẩm và doanh thu 719 thì mình sẽ không
tính vào đấy lại thì mình làm như thế
nào đây là ba điều kiện thực ra các bạn
có thể dùng nhiều điều kiện đều được thì
mình sẽ làm
13 điều kiện rồi nhá bay về nhà cho các
bạn nhé Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc
bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các
bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh
để cập nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng
như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng hoặc
xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở